I think it was very big for seed to
stick with him you know he had been
playing great and he missed the dunk and
you know just like I told him clay
asthma shots tonight I've missed
something and stuff as well just because
you missed the dunk still missed a shot
you know James Laughlin our video
coordinator he came up to me right
before this series started and he said
hey he said you've helped me a lot and
growing since I've been here and this
series we're going to need our bench
like pardon that you stick with them and
continue to get them confidence and so
for a second I caught myself like man
you know we could have cut that to six
and like his and and and and then we
found him and I was just like you know I
just it just came upon me to stick with
him give him some confidence and short
enough you know he had to dunk the next
play and he had a block and so you know
I think that was an important moment and
it's you know we always talk about the
strength in numbers that's coming from a
video coordinator you usually don't get
that from a video coordinator but it
paid for us tonight